[Music]
oh
w
all
[Music]
may peace blessings and mercy of Allah
be on all of you we
welcome all the brothers and sisters
here today as well as the millions
watching this program on television the
world over live through the peace TV
broadcast to this second day of the
10day
International Islamic conference and
exhibition on peace the solution for
Humanity We Begin today's program with
the
Kat by
shik Hassan Ali merhab from
[Music]
Lebanon
Billman
[Laughter]
[Music]
Quan
e
[Music]
sh
thing
[Music]
do
sh
[Music]
in
for
[Music]
all
as
[Music]
l
Earth
[Music]
in
be
[Music]
and
all
[Music]
need
now we have the translation of the karat
by Brother Musa sir
Antonio
and thus we have revealed to you an
Arabic Quran that you may warn the
mother of cities and those around it
about which there is in no doubt a party
will be in paradise and a party in the
Blaze and if Allah will he could have
made them of one religion
but he admits whom he Wills into his
mercy and the wrongdoers have not any
protector nor
helper or have they taken protectors or
Allies besides him but Allah he is the
protector and he gives life to the dead
and he is over all things
competent and in anything over which you
disagree its ruling is to be referred to
Allah
say that is Allah my Lord upon him I
have relied and upon him I turn
back he is the creator of the heavens
and the
Earth he has made for you from
yourselves mates and amongst the cattle
mates he multiplies you thereby there is
nothing like unto him and he is the
hearing all
seeing to him belong the key of the
heavens and the
Earth he extends provision for whom he
wills and restricts it indeed he is of
all things
knowing he has ordained for you of
religion what he has enjoined upon Noah
and that which we have revealed to you
oh
Muhammad and what we enjoined upon
Abraham and Moses and
Jesus to establish the religion and not
to be divided
therein difficult for those who
associate others with Allah is that to
which you invite
them Allah chooses for himself whom he
wills and guides to himself whoever
turns back to
him for the fine Kat by shik Hassan Ali
marhab
from Lebanon and its translation by
Brother Musa s
Antonio who's come all the way from
Australia for this
conference now we begin our formal
program on behalf of the Islamic
Research
Foundation I Dr Muhammad NY am your host
for today evening's program it's my
pleasure to welcome all of you to today
program the speaker for the evening
needs no
introduction yet I will give you a brief
background on this
man the man who has left many speechless
and self
Spellbound by the way of his
presentation of
Islam in the light of the Holy Quran
Hadith and other religious scriptures
as a basis in conjunction with reason
logic and scientific
facts he realized that being a medical
doctor might not be the cure to all
human sufferings as they usually
generate in one's mind the mind that
thinks the mind that
reasons asks questions and generates
doubts hence he started to question this
unsatisfied mind and
started to generate
answers from the resources
available from the worldly knowledge as
well as from the Divine knowledge
available to him he's popular for his
critical analysis and convincing answers
to challenging questions posed by
audiences after his public
talks in the last 11 years
till 2007 Dr Zakir Nik has delivered
more than 1,000 public talks in the USA
Canada UK Saudi Arabia UA Kuwait
Singapore Hong Kong Thailand Guyana
South America Qatar Bahrain South Africa
macius Australia Malaysia and many other
countries in addition to numerous public
talks in India of
course when it comes to a dialogue in
comparative religion no one has the
metal to stand against
him Dr William Campbell of USA has seen
it during the dialogue on the topic the
Quran and the Bible in the light of
science on April 1st
2000 his public dialogue with SRI SRI
Rish Shankar on the topic the concept of
God in Hinduism and Islam in the light
of Sacred Scriptures held in the city of
Bangalore India on January 1st 2006 was
a Grand success in highlighting the
Oneness and unity of
God in May 2000 so much
so shik Ahmed diat May Allah's mercy be
on him said Son what you have achieved
in 4 years had taken me 40 years to
accomplish
alhamdulillah his pursuit to spread the
message of Allah gave birth to the now
increasingly popular TV channel peace t
TV this Grand Event you are witnessing
today may seem huge to you but it's just
a small step for him may Allah subhana
wa ta'ala lead his way and Grant him the
ability to spread God message to mankind
further to speak on today this very
vital topic perplexing the mind of many
non-muslims and
having a lot of faith in the minds of
Muslims but awaiting for some a little
bit more conviction this topic is the
Quran God's
word will be handled today by our
speaker and of course it would be as
usual be followed by the open question
and answer session brothers and sisters
please welcome Dr Zakir
NY
[Music]
[Applause]
alhamdulillah
my respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic
greetings assalamu
alaykum may peace mercy and blessings of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty God
be on all of
you the
topic of this evening's talk of mine
is is the
Quran God's
word many people have a
misconception that Islam is a new
religion that came into existence 1400
years ago and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is the founder of this religion
in fact Islam is there since time
immemorial since man set foot on this
Earth and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is not the founder of this religion
but he is the last and final messenger
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God to whom was revealed the last and
final message the Glorious Quran all all
the
messengers that came before the last and
final messenger Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him they were only sent for a
particular group of people and this
message was supposed to be followed only
by that group of people for a limited
time
period since all the other
Revelations Were Meant only for a
particular group of people and was meant
for a particular time period the
Miracles
performed by the earlier Messengers by
the earlier prophets for example The
Parting of the sea giving life to the
dead it satisfied the people of that
time but today we cannot go back in time
to examine these miracles to verify
these
Miracles but prophet Muhammed peace be
upon him he was not sent only for the
Muslims or only for the Arabs the
Glorious says inia chapter number 21
verse number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to all the creatures as a mercy to
the whole of humanity as a mercy to all
the
worlds since Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was not sent only for the
Muslim of the Arabs but he was sent for
the whole of humanity and he was the
last messenger the miracle that was
given to
him is not time bound the miracle that
was given to him should satisfy the
people at that time even today as well
as to eternity since he is the last
messenger that's the reason the miracle
given to him should satisfy and be
examinable till
eternity though prophet mad peace be
upon him he has done and performed
hundreds of
Miracles but he never emphasized them
and we
Muslims we mainly boast of his ultimate
miracle that is the Glorious
Quran which is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of
almighty God to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad PE upon
him and it is a miracle of all times it
could satisfy the people of that time it
can even satisfy today until the last
day it could be verified and examined
that time it can even be verified today
and inshallah it can be verified and
examined even till the last day that's
the reason it is the Miracle of
Miracles as far as the Quran is
concerned any human being who has the
slightest knowledge of the Quran
irrespective whether he's a Muslim or
non-muslim he will agree that the Quran
was first recited by a man by the name
of Muhammad please be upon him who was
born in the city of Arabia that is
meca there is no difference of
opinion amongst anyone who has the
slightest knowledge of the Quran
irrespective whether it's a Muslim or
non-muslim as far as the origin of this
Quran is
concerned there can be
various allegations replies right or
wrong all of them can be broadly
classified into three
categories the
first that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
was consciously subconsciously or
unconsciously the author of the
Quran the second
category the Quran was written by
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him who
learned it from other sources or he
copied or plagarized from other
religious scriptures
and the third category is that the Quran
has got no human origin no human source
and it is word by word the Revelation
from almighty
God any answers you have for the origin
of the Quran can be broadly classified
into these three categories they can be
100 answers all of them will fit in
these three categories today let us
examine and let us verify the various
answers given by different human
beings time will not permit us to deal
with all of them since the time is
limited I will pick up the more famous
and the more important answers given by
different human
beings first we'll discuss can
Muhammad peace be upon him be the author
of the Quran
whether consciously subconsciously or
unconsciously it is rather a
tragedy
that a person disagrees when a person
disclaims that he is not responsible for
any great work whether literally or
whether
scientific but this is exactly what the
orientalists and the critics of Islam do
when they say Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him while the author of the
Quran never ever has the prophet ever
claimed that he was the author of the
Quran not even a single word of the
Quran he never claimed
it yet when he disclaimed that he was
not the author and the Quran happens to
be a masterpiece in the work of Arabic
so why will a person
disclaim the responsibility of a work
which is a masterpiece why should he
lie and we know from
history from his youth till the day he
claimed
prophethood at the age of 40 years never
has a single lie reported to have been
said by Muhammad peace be upon him
history never reports a single
lie and before he claimed
prophethood he was known for his
truthfulness his honesty and Chastity
and he was given the title
alamin The trustworthy by friends and
foes
alike and there are several
examples even those people after the
prophet claimed
prophethood and they said that he was
lying
yet his enemies his foes they kept their
Valu bills with the prophet for
safety and this is known when the
prophet migrated from Makkah to Madina
and he told his nephew Al be with him
that give this valua BS to the rightful
owners even his
foes even after they said he lied yet
they trusted him and kept the valuables
with him
why and we have the example that Abu
sufyan who was the chief of one of the
tribes of Makkah when he went to Emperor
Hercules and asked him for support
against the prophet and when the emperor
asked him that do you know of any
instance in which the prophet lied or
had he done any Injustice and Abu
sufyan even though he was the enemy of
the Prophet that time he had to reply no
so why should a person with such honesty
and trust and chasti why should he lie
let us analyze the various claims made
by orientalist and the critics of Islam
against Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him we'll just discuss the major
ones one of the claims made by the
critics of Islam is that the prophet he
lied that he was not the author of the
Quran and said it was almighty God for
material
gains we know that there
are many men who claim to be prophets
who claim to be preachers who claim to
be Saints in order to lead a luxurious
life and we have hundreds and thousands
of example in this world today
also but if we see the lifestyle of the
prophet he led a more luxurious life
before he claim Prophet Hood then after
he claimed Prophet
Hood he was
married at the age of 25 to a rich Lady
by the name of Kad Allah be pleased with
her and his life after claiming Prophet
Hood was
unenviable so if he did for money his
life should be better after claiming
Prophet like we see today those people
who claim to be prophets and Saints and
Sages
furthermore we have records in
several including the Nar
by Hadith number 492 that one of his
wives a be pleased with her she said
that there were
times when fire was not lit in the house
for a month or two indicating that food
was not cooked for a month or two in the
house and we only survived on dates and
water and sometimes milk given by the
neighbors there are various
instances and even vers mention in the
Quran that the life was so simple though
he had all the power he was the leader
he could have led the most luxurious
life in the whole of Arabia that the
reason that there was occasion when his
wives they
protested and they said that what is the
need for us to lead such a life when we
can live a much comfortable life
immediately there was a revelation sent
by almighty God in Surah aab chapter
number 33 verse number 28 29 where it
says that oh Prophet tell your consults
tell your wives if they care for the
enjoyment of this world and the glitter
of this world I will set you free to
enjoy this world and give you a handsome
reward but if you care for the life in
the yearafter you'll be
rewarded in the next
life that means the
wives they objected that why should we
lead such a simple life when we can lead
at least a much better life and
immediately the was
revealed but natur wies of the
Prophet then they asked for forgiveness
and they preferred the life in the year
after than this
world we have the example in the
ofth number 465 and 466 where pleased
with him he said that whenever the
prophet received any
gifts he never kept it for himself
neither did he keep it for the future
and he gave it away to the poor
people and it is me mentioned in this
very same Quran in Surah Bak chapter
number
two verse number
79 vote to those who write the book with
their own hands and then say this is
from Allah this is from God to traffic
with it for a miserable price woe to
those for what hands do right and what
they gain there from now imagine if the
prophet would have lied that this
book is from almighty God and when
actually he was the
author there were high possibilities
that one day he would have been
exposed and he would be cursing himself
in the same book that vote to those who
write the book with their own hands and
then say this is from Allah if he would
have written the Quran and attributed to
almighty God would have ever mentioned
such a verse in the
Quran there are some critics who say
that maybe the prophet attributed the
Quran though he was the author because
he wanted Fame status Glory as well as
leadership according to Michael eart he
writes in his book The 100 most
influential persons in the history of
humankind and he
analyzes all the human beings from Adam
peace be upon him till the present
time and undisputedly he puts Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him as number
one as being the most influential person
in the history of
humankind so if you wanted to become a
leader
he didn't have to claim that the Quran
was from God if he actually was the
author and Michael aart he gives reasons
for each person why did he give him
number one number two number three
Etc and at the end of the biography says
that it was the
indisputable secular and religious
influence of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him that makes him the Undisputed
number one person to have the most
influence in human
history Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him if he wanted Glory Fame power
leadership he was so eloquent he had all
the qualities he did not have to falsely
attribute the Quran to almighty God he
had all the
abilities and if we analyze
logically any
person who wants Power Glory leadership
Fame status along with him is
attached good food fancy clothes
magnificent places Monumental
palaces guards
Etc but if you see the lifestyle of
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
men his own clothes he repaired his own
shoes he milked the goat and he did his
own household
work
he sat on the floor and ate when he went
to the
marketplace he didn't have any colorful
guards he was an example of Simplicity
and
humbleness and anyone who invited him
even the poor people he used to accept
their invitation and he used to eat
whatever was served to him so much so
that his enemies they pass a remark
which is mentioned in the
Quran in Surah TBA chapter number n
verse number 61 oh he listens to
everyone his enemies they were angry
what kind of a person is this he listens
to each and everyone even the poor
people and there are many instances and
occasions which are ORD in history and
in
the and one such instances there were a
representative from the Pagan Arabs by
the name
OFA and he comes to the prophet and says
that we will give you all the wealth in
Arabia make you the richest man of
Arabia we will even make you the leader
if you want we'll make you the king only
thing we want from you is that you
should stop spreading this message that
there is one God if the prophet wanted
leadership if he wanted to become the
king he would have accepted this offer
very easy there are several examples we
have the example
that when the Pagan Arabs they told his
uncle Abu
Talib that ask an if you to give up the
message of universal Brotherhood of the
Oneness of God he replies to his uncle
that even if they put the son in my
right hand and the Moon in my left hand
I will not stop my mission I will not
stop spreading this message until the
day I die
or whatever Allah
Wills there was a
time when his son
ibraim he
died and it coincided with an
eclipse so immediately people said ah
this is a sign from God the sun is
mourning because a person has died the
son of Muhammad peace be upon him
immediately the prophet replied and he
said that the Sun and the Moon there are
signs of of Allah subhana wa ta'ala they
do not
Eclipse because of the birth or the
death of any human
being if he wanted Fame and power it was
a very good opportunity said yes because
my son died we see the heavens Amon but
he didn't do that because he a truthful
person some of the critics they say that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
attributed the Quran to almighty God
because he wanted to unite the Arabs
it's known as as the Arab Unity and
Liberation Theory the various theories
propounded by the critics and
orientalist there is not a single verse
in the
Quran which singles out and speaks
exclusively of the Arab Unity not a
single verse exclusively talking about
the unity or the liberation of the Arabs
the Quran has the concept of
umah that's the nation of the whole
humankind
and the
criteria for any human being to be
superior to any other human being it's
not cast it's not color it's not wealth
it's not sex but it is tawa and this is
mentioned in the Quran in chapter number
49 verse number 13 Allah
says oh humankind we have created you
from a single pair of male and female
and have divided you into Nations and
tribes so that you may recognize one
another not that you may despise one
another and the most honored in the
sight of Allah subhana wa tala is the
person who has
tawa the criteria for judgment in the
sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala it's
not cast color creed sex wealth but it
is tawa it is God Consciousness it's
piety
it's
righteousness there are many verses in
the
Quran in order to stand for
truthfulness it even says you can do
that even if you have to go against your
Els there can be a dispute between the
Father and Son between husband and wife
even between relatives if you fight for
the truth Allah says in the Quran in 9
verse number
24 save that be for your
fathers all your
sons or your
brothers or your
spouses or
relatives the we that they Mas the
business in which you deal the houses in
which you
live Allah said says that if you love
all these eight things your fathers your
sons your brothers your spouses your
relatives the business in which you
deal the house in which you live the
wealth you have a m Allah
continues if you love all these things
more than Allah hiso and doing Jihad
striving the way of Allah subhana tala
Allah
says
wait until Allah brings his decisionto
you until Allah brings his destruction
to you and Allah guides not the fasic
people so if the prophet wanted Unity
amongst the Arabs why did he mention
such a ver in the
Quran it further mentioned in the Quran
in Imran 3:
103 hold to the Rope of Allah strongly
and be not divided
so here the prophet is talking about the
unity of the Believers he's not talking
about the unity of the
Arabs and if he wanted to unite the
Arabs he could have easily taken the
leadership and become the leader and the
king and United Arabs
easily there are verses in the Quran
which are contrary to this
Theory it's mentioned in the Quran in
Imran chapter number three verse number
43 it
says and behold the angel said
Mar that Allah has chosen thee and
purified thee and purified thee above
the wom of all
Nations imagine the Quran says that Mary
the mother of Jesus peace be upon him
who was a Jewish she is chosen as the
woman above of all the women in the
world if he wanted Unity among the
Arabs he could have chosen his
mother or his wife or his daughter any
Arab woman as the woman above all the
nations but he goes out of the way to
say mother Mary who was the mother of
Jesus peace be upon Him is the woman
chosen above the woman of all
nation and the reason is it's
immediately mention the next verse in
Surah Imran
3:45 that it is nothing but an
inspiration from almighty God he has no
choice he has no choice to agree or
disagree because this is aah from Allah
subhana
tala so surely there are various other
verses in the Quran several times
including Sur Bak CH 2: 47 which says
that don't you remember the favors which
we have bestowed on the children of
Israel on bani Israel
so all these verses of the Quran if
Prophet Muhammad knows bah he was the
author of the Quran God forbid then why
should he mention such verses in the
Quran the other
allegation or theory is known as the
theory for moral Reformation the prophet
attributed the Quran to almighty God
because he wanted to reform the people
now why should person
lie
because he wants to reform the people
morally if you want to be truthful you
cannot lie to be truthful the means
should match with the
goal and the Quran
says in Surah Anam chapter number 6
verse number
93 that who can be a more wicked person
than a person who invents a lie against
almighty God and says he has received
inspiration when he has
not there were chances that one day
later on the prophet would have been
exposed and he would be calling himself
a wicked person in his own book if you
are the author knows bah God
forbid it's mentioned surah
h chapter 69 verse number 44 45 46
47 that if the prophet
was to invent anything in our name we
would surely hold him by his right hand
and cut off the very artery of his heart
and no one will be able to save him from
our Ro Allah telling the Quran that if
the prophet or if any other human being
had to invent a lie or a saying in the
name of Allah then almighty God would
have held the prophet with his right
hand and would have cut the very artery
of his heart and no one would be able to
save
him there are other people who
say knows bah Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him you are suffering from
mythomania this is a psychological
disorder that a person mentions a lie
and he believes it is the
truth mythomaniac is a person who tells
a lie and he believe that it is a fact
and a
psychologist he treats the person by
giving him more
facts suppose a person says that I am a
king the psychiatrist will not say that
you crazy the psychiatrist will say
you're a king where is the
queen so the Mythic will say the queen
has gone to a mother's
place where is the minister
the minister has died where are your
guards the more you keep on posing facts
then he says I think I'm not the
king and if you analyze the Quran the
Quran mentions about facts keep on
giving facts and figures facts
mentioning about historical
things so the Quran is a teatment for
mythomaniac it's not a book written by
mythomaniac
Noah
furthermore there are some critics who
say and they
believe in the religious illusion Theory
saying that Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he wrote the
Quran from his knowledge from his
experience from various events and
surroundings without knowing that he was
actually the author of the
Quran some say that nah God forbid he
was a crazy person
now no person who has the illusion or no
person who's crazy can be so firm and
accurate constantly for a period of 22
and a half years the Quran wasn't
revealed in one shot or in one day or at
one moment it was revealed over a period
of 22 and a half years no person who has
a illusion or has a Visionary can be so
constant for a period of 22 and a half
years and the
occasions for example in
Sur chapter number 18 verse number
22 when the people asked about the story
of the people of the
cave or about
Zar he said I will answer you
tomorrow but the prophet could not give
the answer tomorrow he kept on
postponing it for 15 days until a
revelation came
in Surah chapter number 18 verse number
23 24 that oh Prophet never
say I will do tomorrow without adding
inshallah if Allah
Wills imagine for 15 days the prophet
was in tension he was sad that why isn't
the way coming so Allah sends thei that
do not say I will say tomorrow without
saying inshallah that if Allah Wills if
God
wills and if he wrote it from his mind
he would have immediately given the
answer or given the answer next day
because there was a delay many people
accepted Islam and they realize that
this cannot be a handiwork of a human
being it has to be a revelation and that
verse is included even today in the
Quran if a person who writes the Quran
why should he mention such a verse in
the Quran indicating that Prophet
Muhammad peah was not crazy and he had
no illusion there are another group of
people who to say the prophet nah was
crazy then we prove him how can he be
crazy then they say no that he are a
liar and we prove he's not a liar then
they say he was both a person can either
be crazy or a liar but he can never be
both well a crazy person when you ask
him a question he immediately gives a
reply whether logical or not a liar will
think and try and give an answer which
is
correct so both are contradicting and we
know that the prophet was neither of the
three neither crazy neither liar neither
both so
surely with all these replies we can
surely realize that Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he was not the auor of
the
Quran let's discuss the second category
that the prophet he learned it from
other sources or he copied or
plagiarized from the other religious
scriptures there are various allegations
made by non-muslims and the critics of
Islam that the prophet he learned the
Quran from a Roman blacksmith who was
just living in the outskirts of
Makkah Allah subhana
tala sends the Revelation inah n chapter
number 16 verse Number 103 we know that
they say that you learned it from
someone but do they not know that his
language is foreign and this Quran is
Arabic pure the Roman blacksmith he
could hardly speak Arabic he was a
foreigner and you're saying that Prophet
learned it from him and this Quran is a
book written in Arabic which is so pure
and eloquent it is like someone saying
that a Chinese man who does not know
English he has taught Shakespeare to
write the
book there are other allegations that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
learned the matter of the Quran
from was the relative of his wife khad
pleas with her